Right here, I've got four different
agents that are looping, calling other
sub agents, and writing all these
prompts for me, and designing systems
for me. But, is this actually
productive, or is that just a cool demo?
Here's your monthly reminder that you
shouldn't be prompting coding agents
anymore. You should be designing loops
that prompt your agents. Boris Cherny
and Peter Steinberg publicly said they
no longer prompt their coding agents.
They write loops. A loop is three
things: a trigger, an action, and a stop
condition. If you're still writing loops
that prompt coding agents, you're
falling behind. You need to build a meta
agent that infers what loops you would
have wanted based on your vibe, and then
write those loops. We're seeing a ton of
talk about agent loops, loop
engineering, whatever you want to call
it. So, I wanted to make a video to
clear up what that actually means.
Because I think that everyone kind of
has their own spin and a different
definition of what this is, and it
applies to everyone very, very
differently. I think that this
definition sums it up pretty well. Loop
engineering is replacing yourself as the
person who prompts the agent. You design
the system that does that instead. A
loop here can be thought of as a
recursive goal, where you define a
purpose, and the AI iterates until
complete. And there's really two most
important pillars of that in my mind,
which are the goal. What is the actual
objective? Something typically
that's objective, not subjective. And
then verification. How does the agent
know what that stop condition is? How
does it check and iterate? So, anyways,
if you take all that advice, and then
you start doing stuff like this, and
designing swarms and fleets of agents
that constantly run 24/7, then you need
to think about what are you actually
doing here? And is this actually moving
the needle? So, first of all, I thought
to myself, how do I actually use agent
loops? Because when you read some of
those tweets that I just showed earlier
in this video, you kind of think to
yourself, okay, if I'm not having five
agents that are continuously around the
clock orchestrating five of their own
agents, then I'm falling behind, or I'm
not using my cloud subscription in the
best way. And I think that that's very
false. Because if you don't understand
what you're doing, then you're probably
just going to scale problems, and you're
going to have a ton of bugs and a ton of
things that you're going to have to fix
later. And also, not all of us are in a
scenario where having agents work 24/7
around the clock actually benefits us.
For example, I don't. I have agents that
do things on a certain cadence and I
have agents that do things based on
certain event actions, but just having
them do 24/7 work for me isn't helpful.
I think if I was working with a team on
a codebase and we were building a
product and we were constantly iterating
and pulling in different things, then it
would maybe make more sense, but for me,
that doesn't apply. So, I just wanted to
come in here, explain this as simple as
I can, and hopefully shed some light on
where you guys can start applying loops
into your workflows and why and how. So,
I actually built an agent loop for this
HTML that we're going to look at today,
and it basically went through a ton of
different sources. It checked 45
sources, whether that was articles,
YouTube video transcripts, X posts. It
looked through a ton of stuff, and then
it kept looping on this until it had a
good idea of what to build. And then
once it built this HTML, this wasn't V1.
This was probably V7. It had to keep
checking, screenshotting, reviewing,
iterating, and then it finally said,
"Okay, we're done. This is what we got."
So, let me walk through this with you
guys. An agent loop is just an AI that
reasons on what to do, acts on what to
do, starts implementing, and then it
observes the result. And it will do that
over and over and over until some sort
of goal is met, until it knows we've hit
the stop criteria, this is good, I'm
going to stop now. And a really simple
visual that I like to think about is AI
is never perfect, right? It's never
going to one-shot something and you just
accept that final output. And so, if we
have attempts on the x-axis and we have
quality on the y-axis, let's think about
this. On attempt one, if you are just
giving your agent some sort of simple
task, maybe you get to like, let's just
say attempt one, you get to 50%, and
then you look at that and say, "Okay,
here are some changes to make." And then
by attempt two, maybe you bump up
another five or 10%. And every time that
you give more feedback and iterate, you
just kind of keep moving up on quality
until you hit somewhere where you're
okay with that, 90, 95%. And so, the
whole idea is why don't we outsource
this part, this feedback and iteration
loop, to an agent rather than having the
human do that? Cuz this is going to
happen either way. So, if we have an
agent do that instead of a human, then
what might happen is on attempt one, we
will go straight up to here. And then we
can give a little bit more feedback. And
then by attempt, you know, three or
four, we're already so much higher than
where we would have been without sort of
that agent verification loop right
there. And that's why a lot of people
are explaining this in a different way,
where some people have the think act
see, you know, we basically like reason
act observe reason act observe. Some
people have the model just going back
and forth with tools back and forth back
and forth. Some people have just, you
know, a goal that runs completely
unattended. And some people are using
these like fleets of agents with
managers prompting other agents
prompting other agents. And it's just
like, you know, those Russian nesting
dolls. So that's why I wanted to put
this into kind of the main pillars,
which I think are reason act observe.
Think of this like a smart intern that
you don't micromanage. You hand them a
goal, they figure out what to do next,
they check their own work, and they go
again, and then they only come back to
you and say, "Hey, I'm done." After they
probably checked it a few times and made
some changes. So you would say, "Okay,
Claude code, here's what I want you to
do." We as humans are really, really
good at defining what we want. We're
really good at defining an end goal. And
then on top of that, we have to say,
"Okay, how do you know when that is
done?" So when you're making a cake, you
stick the fork in it, and when it comes
out and it doesn't have batter all over
it, that means it's done. How do you
tell your agent something as objective
as possible, what is the stop criteria,
what is the definition of done? And so
what it will do is it will reason, it
will plan out, and then it will start to
implement. After it implemented, it will
observe. So maybe that's visual
verification, maybe that's running an
actual code test. Whatever it means to
verify, it has to verify. And then after
it looks at the results, it will say,
"Okay, did I meet this done criteria? If
no, I'm going to act again, then observe
again, and then reason. Otherwise, I'm
going to stop, and I'm going to say,
"Okay, Mr. or Mrs. Human, I am done."
And what's really interesting is that
the majority of tasks don't need loops.
What I've started doing is for the
majority of my tasks, I will build some
sort of loop, but it's just because of
the verification, right? This piece is
so important, the verification loop. But
a lot of times, you don't need some sort
of massive agent architecture in order
to run this sort of like dynamic looping
workflow. You You just get it done with
one simple terminal session and a good
prompt. You can have the speed just a
solo loop, which is what I'm typically
doing the most. One agent that's
reasoning, that's acting, observing, and
repeating. And I'll show you guys some
examples of what these loops might look
like in just a sec. You can have a maker
checker, where you have one agent that
does the thing and then one agent that
grades the thing and gives feedback. Or
you can have this sort of manager with a
bunch of helpers. And then as as long as
you've got one main agent that's
orchestrating the whole thing, then you
can build these loops in so many
different ways. So, let me just show you
guys a few examples that I pulled. These
first two that I'm going to show you
were actually from this loop library
that Matthew Berman published. He
created this loop library, which is a
list of agent loops that you can use,
and people can go submit their own. So,
kind of cool to just go in here and play
around with and see what's available.
And I grabbed two for these first two
demos. So, this was the first one right
here. It was a  goal prompt in
Cloud Code to make me a thumbnail. So, I
told it basically what to use to make
them. It says, "Make 10 thumbnail
concepts and score each one against Mr.
Beast YouTube thumbnails using a rubric.
Clarity at small size, curiosity,
emotional pull, visual contrast." Stuff
like that. And after it makes those 10,
it selects the top three, it identifies
the weakest part of each concept, it
improves them, rescores them, and then
it continues iterating on on the
strongest concept until it's satisfied.
So, that's one of the issues with this
prompt here is that
the definition of done was "until you're
satisfied." And sometimes you have to
have these subjective sort of grading
criteria, but you want to get it
objective as objective as possible. The
best agent loops are where you literally
say, "Keep iterating until X metric
equals Y result." You can see right here
what it did is it created 10. We've got
number one, we've got number two, number
three, number four, number five. It
ended up choosing that number one was
one of the top contenders, number two,
and so was number eight. So, then it
iterated on these. You can see here's
number one original, here's number one
V2, here's number two original, here's
number two V2, and here's number eight
original, and here's number eight V2.
And what it did is after those version
twos of all of it, it said, "Okay,
number eight's the best. So, here is
number eight V3." And so, this is the
final thumbnail that we got after we ran
this goal, which took Claude Code 27
minutes right there. So that's one quick
example of the loop. You can see it was
it was scoring each of these, and that's
how it decided on the winner. But the
one thing here is that these scores were
subjective. So if we wanted to improve
this flow, we would try to figure out
how do we make this scoring more
objective? And maybe what we would want
to do is create a separate sub agent
that was a dedicated scorer, and we
would prompt that scoring agent and run
that through a bunch of evaluations so
that we could feel more confident about
its scoring ability. Anyways, let's take
a look at the next one. So the next one
was another slash goal, as you can see
right here. This one took 37 minutes.
And the prompt for this one was right
here, straight from Matthew Berman's
Loop Library. I'm not going to read this
whole thing. You guys can pause it right
there if you want to see. But it was
basically supposed to make a plane using
3.js. So I'll open that up right here.
We can see this is the spinning plane
that it made. We can sort of zoom in. We
can move it around. And that is what we
got. Now from a looping perspective,
what it had to do was it had to build it
and then verify. Open up the browser,
spin it around, see if it works, see if
it's rendering properly, and then it
kept iterating until we finally got this
version. And as you can see still, like
it's not perfect. There's some things we
want to change. I think it was supposed
to be see-through like this so we could
like actually go look inside. But this
is so much better than it would have
been if I didn't give it that slash goal
with the criteria, and I just said build
me a 3D plane with, you know, 3.js. So
that's one of the key takeaways here.
Agent loops and goals are not supposed
to give you 100% perfect output. They're
supposed to help you get much closer on
the first try. And here's another great
example of that with the whole
subjectivity thing. Here's the last one
I did, which is a a prompt that I had
Claude Code make, a slash goal. It was
looking at this famous picture of the
Beatles Abbey Road. And then what I told
it to do was recreate this without using
image generation. So just recreating
this using like HTML or CSS or whatever
it wants to do. And then it goes through
and it creates, you know, version one,
version two, version three. And it ended
up stopping after version seven. You can
see the prompt here says, "If the
average is above nine or equal to nine,
then stop." And that's when you end. The
other thing it said is hard cap on eight
passes. So, it was getting near that cap
either way. But, these images are not
very good. What we can see though is
that it did its verification. So, each
time it went through and created the
HTML, it had to actually put it in a
browser and then it would take a
screenshot of it. You can see here's the
screenshot for number one, here's
version two, here's version three,
here's version four. So, we can see it
in real time getting better and better
with each version, with each iteration.
But still, this is the one that it gave
me at the end and obviously that looks
nothing like the picture. We've got the
car here, we've got the trees, we've got
the road, we've got yellow, black, gray,
light blue, just like the actual image.
If I go back here, did I say yellow? I
meant to say white. White, black, dark
gray, light blue. And so, obviously it's
nothing like it. If we would have done
this with image generation, it could
have been probably much closer. But I
just wanted to try how that would work
with pure code. The point being, it had
the verification checks, it had the
ability to take screenshots and look
through each of its iterations,
understand how did this still not look
like the reference image, and what
changes do we need to make each time?
And so, that's why a loop is only going
to be as good as it's done check, as the
done criteria. So, there's two things
you need to think about before you build
your first loop or your goals. What does
done mean? And then how will it check?
Because let's say you're building an
actual game, a game that you can open up
on your PC and play. It would have to
check that in many ways. It would have
to check visually, it would have to
check functionally, and it would have to
play the levels and see if anything
breaks. If you're writing some sort of
like script, how does it check? It
doesn't need to check visually, it just
needs to check flow. It needs to check
that it sounds like your tone of voice.
It needs to check in other ways. So,
based on what you're building, the
verification checks obviously look
different and it's your job to make sure
that your agents have the right tools in
order to do those checks. And then of
course, on the other side, what does
done mean? Like I mentioned earlier, if
you can get as objective as possible
with a specific metric, then that's
best. But sometimes you can't. Sometimes
you have to say until you're 100%
confident, right? And so like, my most
common use of these loops is when I use
hyper frames in Cloud Code to edit
videos because I will basically chuck it
in, do a slash goal, and it does
everything for me. It has to get the
transcript, cut out the mistakes and the
pauses, it has to make the beats, it has
to sync the beats, it has to obviously
render them, and then it has a ton of
verification on making sure that all of
the beats are in bounds and that they
line up with the transcript correctly.
And that is how you're able to see a lot
of these people say, "Okay, I did this
with one shot, with one prompt." Because
it was a loop, because it had
verification and iteration. So, what
makes a loop actually work? A checkable
goal, a hard stop, good tools, memory, a
separate checker, planning first,
logging, and then making it make sense
with the cost. Because a lot of times
these loops can run for a long time, and
especially if you have a pretty hard
goal, a goal that might take a lot of
iteration, and then if the done criteria
is also very hard, where maybe it just
can't actually ever hit that, then that
thing's going to run for a long time.
So, I've had a couple loops that have
gone for 12 hours plus, and they're just
not like super useful to me. Most of the
time when I'm running loops that run for
a while, it's usually more like these.
It's usually things that take like 35
minutes or maybe a couple hours, but I
don't need a loop that's going to run
for 4 days straight. I just don't really
need that. So, another kind of message
that I'm trying to send here is just
because you're seeing someone like Peter
Steinberger saying something like this,
doesn't actually mean that this applies
directly to you and your use case.
Because he's a hardcore coder, he's
building agents, he works at OpenAI.
This probably makes a lot of sense for
the way that he works and has probably
10xed his productivity. And that's the
cool thing about AI is that it because
it's going to seep into every single
vertical and every single role, not
everyone will use it the same. So, it's
good to stay up to date with what people
like Peter Steinberger are saying, but
that doesn't mean you have to drop
everything right now and go try it. Or
maybe it's good to try it, but that
doesn't mean you have to fully integrate
it into every single Cloud Code session
forever.
So, anyways, coming from a non-coding
background, coming from a perspective of
someone who uses Cloud Code all all
time, 24/7, but I use it for knowledge
work rather than massive database code
base refactors and building software and
building apps every day. That's kind of
the way that I feel about these agent
loops, and I've been seeing a ton of
stuff about them lately, so I felt like
I needed to come in here and just share
my opinions on it. Some of you guys may
disagree with this, but that's the way
that I've been using them because I do
use them. I just don't go for those
fancy runs that run for like 3 days
straight. A lot of times if I have a big
goal, I will shoot off a nice chunky
loop before I go to bed, and I can wake
up with something that's ran for maybe 4
or maybe 8 hours, and that is truly very
beneficial. But a lot of that stuff is
more experimental for me, and then I'm
able to take that output I got from the
overnight run, and then chuck it back
into some more loops or iterate on that
myself as a human. So, there's a little
bit more detail that was covered in this
slide deck as well as this full audit,
which is way more wordy and super ugly
to look at, but I will attach both of
these sources in my free school
community if you guys want to check all
that out. The link for that is down in
the description. You'll hop in the free
school community, you'll go to
classroom, you'll click on all YouTube
resources, and you can find everything
in there. But, that's going to do it for
today. So, if you guys enjoyed the video
or you learned something new, please
give it a like. Helps me out a ton. And
as always, I appreciate you guys making
it to the end of the video, and I'll see
you on the next one.
Thanks, guys.